I'm looking in the webcam let's do this
this is being shot with the new MacBook
Airs webcam this is being shot with my
10 year old MacBook Pro and this is the
surface laptop 3 and the Google pixel
book oh and the Dell XPS 13 and this is
my iPhone Elevens front-facing camera I
think you get the point
laptop webcams sort of suck which is why
I'm trying to shoot most of this video
using the MacBook Airs webcam including
these beauty shots
[Music]
it's very hard to shoot a video with a
laptop webcam very hard why the MacBook
Air well I started reviewing this new
model which has a great new keyboard at
$999 price right when the world was
forced to communicate via video chatting
because coronavirus and then it hit me
this thing has an outdated 720p webcam
while other laptops like the pixel book
go can do Full HD
besides my iPhone 11 has a 4k selfie
camera so I decided to test all these
laptops and my iPhone in a few different
conditions test one great lighting
conditions on a nice partly cloudy day
aka nature's softbox all the webcams did
a solid job of basic balance and color
okay maybe not the Dell XPS 13 heck even
my old MacBook Pros 480p cam looks
better yet you can see that the MacBook
Airs cam is much grainy er than the
Google pixel but goes crisp camera and
well you compare to the iPhone which
actually picked up this thing in my
tooth that I had no idea was there test
check back light we all know this
difficult webcam shot big window and the
back of you makes you look like a ghost
or an angel the air actually didn't do
too bad adjusting to the lighting it
gets real bad there but though the pixel
book was again sharper and not as grainy
waving test and oh boy that dad looks
like garbage I truly look like an angel
oh right and the iPhone yeah I look good
[Music]
test three low light
hello don't worry I'm wearing like 16
sweatshirts as you can see the macbook
air quality is no good in fact in
low-light I'd prefer my 10 year old
MacBook Pro actually doesn't look
horrible Oh Dell again Dell said the
camera and the new XPS 13 is the
smallest ever in a laptop and it's
always looking at technologies to
improve performance the pixel book did a
decent job but not as good as the
surface laptop and the quality is much
better and well of course the pretty
much not even worth comparing this to
any of the other webcams good night so
what do we learn from all this well
unless you've got a pixel book go your
laptop's webcam probably sucks and none
of them are as good as those selfie
cameras on our smartphones why well for
one thing we don't go around taking
photos with our laptops
that's a cute photo plus laptop screens
are always much thinner than the
thinnest phones sure you could always
buy an external webcam or just use your
phone but I think we can all agree it's
about time that Apple put a decent
camera on its otherwise almost perfect
MacBook Air
[Music]